por tercera vez un sismo sacudió a
méxico un 19 de septiembre el movimiento
telúrico de magnitud 7,7 reavivó los
peores miedos de los ciudadanos que
conmemoraban los mortíferos terremotos
de 1985 y 2017 una hora después de que
las alarmas por el simulacro anual
callarán a las 13 05 hora local comenzó
el temblor la verdad es que momentos
como este son muy difíciles sobre todo
revive la experiencia pasada el último
sismo sobre todo y pues nos metemos un
anuncio para que el gobierno pueda
realmente entender lo que la ciudadanía
en todo momento no en el sismo sino
también antes y posterior al sismo
es un aviso más de la naturaleza para
que hagamos bien las cosas si bien las
secuelas de este terremoto no han sido
tan letales como los pasados la huella
psicológica es evidente muchos
ciudadanos tuvieron que ser atendidos
por crisis nerviosas las autoridades
mexicanas reportaron un muerto en un
centro comercial de manzanillo hasta las
16 horas del 19 de septiembre se han
registrado 217 réplicas del sismo de 77
ocurrido en michoacán en ciudad de
mexico se emitió una orden de evacuación
obligatoria bien no se reportaron daños
muchos lloraban recordando el terremoto
de hace 5 años que mató a 375 personas y
la coincidencia de las fechas es un día
de luto desde se declaró desde 1985 y
después en 2017 por eso se iza la
bandera media asta
pero no hay repito científicamente nada
que no se establezca algo sobre el 19 de
septiembre la coordinación nacional de
protección civil de méxico descartó
activar la alerta de tsunami sin embargo
advirtió de variaciones anómalas del
nivel del mar de hasta 82 centímetros en
la región donde se originó el sismo